hidey-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we are going to watch a
video from top reward tier patron the
man the only single human being in the
world why is this thing I mean singular
human being who has a real rejects
tattoo Erick horseman horseman handsome
man from Atlanta this video is called
deaf people answer commonly googled
questions about being deaf we recently
just met another deaf person you do
exciting times we're living in and it
made me wish that I wasn't such a
heathen and I knew yes yes sure Eric
says ok here's a vid pretty tame and
short but means a lot one of my best
friends growing up was deaf and bullied
it led me to learn ASL which has been
one of the most important things I've
done it's like living on a strange
planet not able to communicate verbally
but finding a whole new world of
physical manifestation of words in life
and hey an alien race you can only hear
sound invades I'm good awesome
that sounds great Eric you were always
positive let's do this
[Music]
mixie this definitely video you must
watch do deaf people think who asks that
what a dumb question these are common
questions
[Music]
their deaf accent that's a cool way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow this is like shocking despite it
shocking that people actually ask these
questions didn't know what what driving
would be like yeah
[Music]
that's an engine okay I like that
question
[Music]
haha Oh fascinating
[Music]
probably right and imagine so
[Music]
oh really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of course
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that bad
[Music]
two people are probably super observant
[Music]
my wood huh
what's channel I'm genuinely gonna ask
why would someone a BuzzFeed ok fuzzyby
why would someone be afraid I feel like
they're being judged or something
because there's this barrier and
communication I think they mean afraid
in the sense that like when you're
confronted with the situation especially
with another person where you don't know
what to do and you can't rely on your
you know if you don't know ASL your
basic form of communication I think that
is kind of a roadblock for some people
that can freeze you up you know or maybe
people don't want to engage because they
don't know how I feel like in those
social situations especially awkward
things can probably happen from from
hearing folks I can imagine so Andrew
Gordon one of his best friends is deaf
and so hanging out with them Annette and
to me it's fun sometimes I just assume
like people probably treat them a little
differently or ask them like the most
generic kind of questions do you think
so I'm not gonna ask them or treat them
like this is my in say like I don't
think it's right to treat people
differently for something like that the
only awkward interaction was just when I
would ask a question like my question
was you know like as people naturally
communicate what is it was old questions
that the people naturally communicate
with their hands sometimes are very
animated with their hands do you ever
get a little confused at they might be
doing sign language and then so Andrew
had to interpret all this her prevent
and then he just went but take like a
minute for me to like communicate that
and you to interpret it in sign language
and she says no like that's a really as
bad as awkward as yet some of these
questions though like the first few and
everyone will think and laugh and things
like that the head voice one I thought
was an interesting one but yeah some of
these questions are like what do you
think a deaf person's experience yeah
they're not like a vegetable they're not
in a coma
you know I imagine that it can be
isolating for certain deaf people
especially in a society in a world where
most people are not deaf so if people I
imagine because they don't want to deal
with the uncomfortableness and the
language barrier they just flat-out
choose not to communicate with them we
didn't grow up in a school where there
was anyone
was deaf so I don't know what like
bullying is light for deaf people I can
imagine that some deaf people endure
that No especially at the hands of kids
yeah especially I mean I know that they
addressed in this video your voice you
know especially if you're a deaf child
figuring out your voice or trying to use
your voice they said deaf accent like I
feel like that would sadly be kind of a
prime target you know my choice to make
sure I don't act differently just make
sure to treat everyone equally
especially actually would meeting will
and will have seen some of these videos
so I'll just say last thing I want is
even for that to come across uh-oh I'm
aware he's deaf and I'm not really hard
like this I don't want him to think I'm
treating him differently because he's
deaf you know because I feel like deaf
people probably especially if you're
like born deaf or develop something at
an early age you are probably a little
bit more observant in picking up facial
cues and how someone's emotions are
responding to a conversation or a
situation than most people so I feel
like the best way to just go about
anything just be as sincere as possible
yeah I guess I was a little bit
surprised by in this video that most
commonly asked questions about being
deaf because like they're just people
that's great like a basic humanity I
don't know like they're just people I
feel like we learned that really young
deaf people are just people who cannot
hear to varying degrees blind people
cannot see but otherwise they're just
yeah and so it seems really weird yeah
that some people would have such a
disconnect from that you know like do
deaf people think or do deaf people
laugh like oh my god that's some like
foreign being some weird segregation
there's one sense impaired and they they
say I don't know how much truth there is
but they say if one of your senses is
taken away or or isn't functioning for
whatever reason your other senses
compensate and get strong that's why
daredevil can fight crime exactly all
blind people I do that have magic powers
they all have a mentor and met
but the ones I found really interesting
in this video were I honestly didn't
know what the rules were about driving
because I know that like even for
hearing people it's illegal to drive
with two headphones in so I assume that
hearing is probably valued as part of
the safety of being on the road but
apparently yeah that made a lot of sense
to me that of course driving is a visual
experience I think the only sounds you'd
have to be really looking out for are
sirens but those you can see that would
make sense and then the other one was
the head voice because yeah it's like if
you didn't necessarily grow up hearing
people speak and you have you know sign
language and the written word as your
guideline for language yeah like what
does it come across as in your head like
that's a very broad abstract idea you
know and that's something I find very
interesting and I'm glad they touched on
but John do deaf people feel I don't
think so
not physically no you can punch a deaf
person you can poke them they won't even
know no nerve endings no nerve can deaf
people see you do they eat eat what
happens if a deaf person needs to take a
shower
hope you got no they're not Siri
question we googled all these question
all these actually the questions I came
up with from us constantly Google the
more I see things like this the more I
do want to take out some time to learn
at least the alphabet or learn some
basic sign language just because that
seems like a good idea you know people
do like foreign language gibberish like
King don't know I like that can you can
you do that with like sign language yes
is there like a really derogatory a
snide prejudiced joke yeah like there
yeah I'm sure somebody's found out away
and mock silent why would you do that I
don't know I think you just look like an
idiot though I think that's the joke are
you sure I've just succeeded in that
alright guys well this was a
very fascinating video and I did learn
some stuff too there's some really
interesting things guys you can
subscribe to BuzzFeed video subscribe
but the real rejects click that
notification Bell will if you're
watching what's up buddy and Eric
Horstman I think you should get another
tattoo but of our channel name the real
rejects written out in sign language Oh
a [ __ ] stamp just like all the letters
across your back could be a body tattoo
oh yeah it could be like a full back
piece is this a map nope just a real
Regis is this prison break one day I
will buy you a cup of coffee in person
come on my kidding knowing you I'm gonna
buy you a bunch of alcohol
I'll buy you a handle of rum yeah I
handle moonshine or something I don't
even think you drink anything else I'm
gonna get you like a latex onesie and
you had just let you do your thing Eric
thanks so much buddy does a great video
see you guys